um the us to israel and she's done lots
of wonderful work and shafi is was her
phd advisor
so um she was also a student and speaker
at women in theory in past
so let's welcome elect
hi everyone uh good morning
hopefully i'll keep the energy
reasonably high in case people are a bit
tired
um so indeed i'm a cryptographer right
now i'm faculty and associate professor
at richmond university in israel and
also senior scientist at ntt research
um i had to think a little bit about
what to talk to you guys about i
kind of toyed around with a couple
options i've decided this is what you're
going to hear um so this will make sense
as the talk goes on but i'll be talking
about something called zero knowledge on
distributed data
and talking in particular about how this
gives us useful applications within some
setting of cryptography so this is
cryptography in itself of course
um i'm going to keep things relatively
high level at some point they'll
dig a little bit deeper
but kind of collectively this is based
on a line of work two kind of combined
lines one together with dan bonnet henry
corgan gibbs niv bilboa and valeshai and
the other one with the authors over here
so
new vival and ariel
and at any point feel free to jump in if
you have questions if you have comments
or complaints
uh we'll see how it goes
okay so so push everything to the side
for a second and i want to talk a little
bit at a high level about what is my
research kind of geared at
um and and the core focus of this i
would say is centered around this notion
of secure multi-party computation okay
so what is this thing well the goal is
that we want to jointly compute across
sensitive data
without revealing the data itself okay
so more concretely say we have a
collection of parties maybe the people
in this room each of you has a deep dark
secret x-i okay don't tell anybody what
your secret is
and the goal is to design protocols for
us to communicate back and forth such
that at the end of the day if we're
given some public function f we want to
know what is f on our secrets maybe this
is some statistical information maybe
this is
who is uh you know makes the most money
or who does something of this form
but ultimately at the end of this this
discussion back and forth
we will all learn f applied to
everybody's influence
but in a way
that you don't learn anything else about
the inputs
okay so for example if we learn who here
makes the most money
um
we've got some candidates
maybe not some of the students maybe it
is blockchain of course right
uh so so once we learn this outcome we
know something about other people's
inputs for example i know whoever makes
the most money makes more money than i
do and and everybody else also makes
less money than them so that's that's
some information but you can
characterize that
basically the only information that's
being revealed is what can be inferred
by your own inputs beforehand together
with the function output
okay and i'm a cryptographer i assume
the world is out to get me so i even
want to be able to do this and to have
this guarantee even if a subset of these
parties of you folks here are acting
adversarially and i'll talk a little bit
later about what what exactly do we mean
by that
okay so the first question you might ask
this sounds great sounds a little bit
too good to be too true is this even
possible secure computation
the answer is yes
so this is something that goes back to a
beautiful line of works from the 1980s
but
in in one of two cases either for
example if i can assume that a majority
of you are acting honestly and following
the protocol
or if i can assume that at least
the everyone kind of in the world has
some computational bounded power for
example they can't factor the product of
two large prime numbers okay um so so
this is you can see
we have some culprits here in the
audience and this one is jaffee
um and so so this is kind of
where we were back in the 80s and over
the the last decades there's been a
tremendous amount of work and progress
in this area
and kind of fast forwarding to today
roughly speaking where we stand is that
um for for specific targeted tasks
this is there already
okay google is using some of these
protocols um a number you signal for
example telegram a lot of different
places are using secure computation
protocols
but right now kind of the where this is
being used is more for like specific
functions f that have targeted protocols
designed for them
so running over here a little bit so
i'm a bit winded
okay um and for for general computations
this iview is a very exciting kind of
border here where we're not quite there
and and i'll talk this is kind of though
the main message
of the talk today is going to be that
the costs are still too high we're
trying to get the costs down
that if i don't care about security i
can do it with some cost
in order to achieve security you have to
pay more in communication computation
what have you
okay so so this is mostly what i'm going
to be focusing at of looking at general
functions f and trying to figure out how
can we try to decrease the overheads of
these protocols
we're going to indeed so when i'm
looking at overhead of these things
um in particular i'm interested in the
communication overhead and there's a
number of reasons for that first of all
from a theoretical standpoint it's a
very crisp nice kind of thing to study
but also the practical level turns out
computation is becoming cheaper and
cheaper and cheaper and communication in
a lot of different settings is the
actual concrete
bottleneck
okay
so so let's ask ourselves what is the
communication complexity of securely
evaluating some function f
okay remember so the baseline here if i
don't care about security
um of course there's an entire area of
communication complexity also very
interesting area of computer theoretical
computer science
i'm kind of not going to go into that
where if there's specific functions f
maybe you can do better than what i have
written here
but in any case no matter what the
function f is
i can always just so let's say i'm just
looking at two people here
i can just send you my input
you compute
f on x and whatever your input is y and
you send it back
okay so this is always like this is sort
of our ground comparison point
okay so what about secure computation
i told you we can do this since the 80s
and it turns out that from the 80s up
until 2009
all of the solutions that we had
required communication complexity that
instead of scaling just with the input
and output
scaled with the representation size of
the function okay so slightly more
complete uh concretely
suppose that you take this function and
you express it as some circuit
okay so say like a boolean circuit or
arithmetic circuit over some ring or
your gates or additions and
multiplication gates
okay and unfortunately in many cases
this function can be much much bigger
than just the inputs and outputs
small input small output circuit
so so this by the way on its own it's
like i could talk a lot about it this is
a fascinating area it really seemed like
we were kind of stuck was that even
possible
in 2009 and you've probably heard of
this notion of fully homomorphic
encryption in fact so the this is the
girdle prize of this year this was craig
gentry um
and
we know by kunta nathan
so this this fully homomorphic
encryption allowed us a way of getting
the communication complexity much lower
and just very very loosely for those who
haven't heard of it
fhe is something that kind of allows you
to compute on encrypted data so roughly
speaking i would send you an encryption
of my input you would sort of do the
computation on this encrypted value and
send the answer back
and and of course i'm stuck in here
there's one other approach that we know
how to do this based on something called
homomorphic secret sharing which also i
could talk a lot a lot about
okay so so in theory this is fantastic
we have very small overhead we're happy
fortunately in practice there's a lot of
gap there
okay
so certainly in certain applications fpg
and so forth are very practical or can
be quite practical
but in the general case
these things
are very expensive so for example even
even though this is asymptotically
fantastic the constants here are kind of
worse than the original version
okay so in practice the sort of the
baseline here
is going to be taking whatever the
circuit representation is
and the communication that we require or
or that these protocols have
will be kind of some number of
ring elements whatever
whatever the circuit is over so it's
either 0 1 or summary r
for every single multiplication gate in
the circuit we have to each communicate
some constant number of ring elements
okay this constant
i'm going to denote by alpha and i'm not
telling you what it is yet
it depends a lot on different settings
okay so actually let me pause here for a
second are there any questions so far
okay so indeed what is this alpha and
this of course depends a lot
before i get to that let me say a little
bit about
the high level structure of how these
protocols are designed
okay
so essentially every protocol that i
know that that gives you the security
that you ultimately want
okay so this is the
fiery uh devilish fellow over here
um when i was talking about adversarial
behavior
ultimately we want to be able to protect
even against people who are doing
whatever they can to try to destroy the
protocol okay this is the goal security
against those gu that guy okay
you don't want to run into him on the
street she looks very cute doesn't he
okay but in order to get to this high
level security
what happens in these protocols is that
you first
achieve some weaker notion of security
which i'm going to call passive security
okay and here
here you're you're sort of assuming
that the the bad guy is in the protocol
are actually following the steps that
they're supposed to be doing so if it
says take these values multiply them and
send that as a message that's really
what he's going to send
okay
um
okay and interestingly enough even
against the setting
there's a lot to hide and to protect
because for example it could be trying
to sort of learn more information
combining different parties together who
are not supposed to
to share information and this could
actually reveal secrets
okay so so what happens
is you first design a protocol against
this weaker setting
and then you somehow boost up
this boosting is going to be a big focus
of my talk
okay
so
this this framework was originally put
forth in uh
it is gmw this is a gold medalist
and i'll say just just kind of one
sentence about how do you do this
so in the original work here what they
did is that each time you would send a
message you'd basically pair along with
it
some sort of proof that this was the
right thing you were supposed to send
okay so that was the original
kind of compiler approach since then
there's been a lot of different things
things like maybe you do multiple
executions of the protocol and you kind
of open up some of them something called
cut and choose
um you use kind of
authenticated beaver triples don't
ask me afterward what on earth does that
mean
um these are certain useful correlations
but the bottom line this is still a very
interesting and important area of
research of doing this
and one of the reasons for that is that
this error
tends to incur a lot of costs
okay so going back to this alpha this
kind of constant overhead communication
cost
in in some of these settings you can get
passive secure protocols with very small
over like very small alpha of course you
could hope for even sublinear here
but suppose even like alpha equals one
which is which is doing pretty well
um but so prior to kind of this line of
work that i'm going to be talking about
and the best possible thing up here
required at least twice the
communication overhead
okay this is kind of in the good case
where you were your circuit was over a
large field if you over a boolean
circuit sometimes this overhead was as
much as like 40.
okay
so uh so very kind of the takeaway maybe
piece of of this talk or one
one takeaway
is that by using the techniques i'm
going to be telling you about
we can get this so that the overhand
is sublier in the circuit size
it's not affecting the communication
uh
you're ignoring that you just look at
the line
yes yes so you can actually formalize
the separation of these two different
settings for example based on
computational assumption
so these things and
either in the honest majority case say
black box using png or even even
information
um in the dishonest majority case which
i'll just briefly mention you can also
get results in like uh uh
this is also relevant because you still
could talk about the active security but
it's a different story for a dishonest
majority
yeah no i work for the like
uh this alpha
is
uh
and
statement you can get this also if you
put heavy assumptions on
for example if i put smarts and synonyms
and things like that that gives you the
problem is that the efficiency is
okay my question is
okay
so again so this is kind of uh
yes within the setting which is
uh so there's different ways of formally
defining a separation here certainly
also
maybe another thing i should mention so
when i say like in theory versus in
practice
um
like the stuff that's being implemented
aside from you know a couple startups i
suppose
uh is is in the in practice category
okay so pausing here again any questions
about the high level kind of goal so
again the goal is is to to do this
transformation where the communication
overhead is sublinear in the circuit
size
let me let me explain what do i need my
advertised here um even just one
execution but what i mean is that the
final communication so this is
communication like alpha times size of c
times number of variants
this will be that plus something similar
in c
so it's you know it's like alpha plus a
little bit but if size of c is large
this is what i mean
uh could you explain again why do you
experiment with classic security like
what is that
allowed to do
so the adversary is
is required to follow the protocol
so if you have some specification of for
example sampling random bits it has to
simply written bits the true randomness
and if it says the code says for the
next message function given the values
here compute this and send that to
whoever that is following so that is
what it what it does do and the question
is you know where is achieving like why
is it adversarial
so for example in the honest case you're
not supposed to share information with
anybody else
so i'll give you something that will
give you something
and i'm assuming that you were not
combining these pieces
but in the semi honest case there's some
fractional people who are wrapped and
and we assume that they could be
colluding with each other so they're
secret like whatever i'm sending you two
would come together
okay excellent so and the star of the
show is the title of this talk
is this notion of zero knowledge on
distributed data and let me take this
step by step
okay before before anything else
um let me mention zero knowledge on its
own okay so this is something again
shafi
did a number of very influential things
including zero knowledge
um and uh and
in a zero large interactive proof we
have the following setting okay there's
a prover and a verifier
there's some public language think of
maybe an np language graph colorability
something like this
and both of us know some candidate graph
say some input x
and the prover is trying to prove to the
verifier this graph x is three colorable
it's in the language
okay so the interactive proof we want it
to be complete that is a function of
talking back and forth if if p is honest
and x truly is in the language
then at the end of this communication
the verifier will accept
once soundness
that if this graph is not recolorable if
x is not in the language
then no matter what a cheating prover is
doing
then the verifier will will reject with
some good probability
or kind of the the converse here sorry
not the converse the country positive if
v accepts that means x is in the
language
and this tricky third property of zero
knowledge
says that
even if the verifier is corrupt
then
through through this conversation it
still doesn't learn anything beyond
the fact that x is in the language
okay so for example suppose
suppose here
we're talking about some language that's
not easy to decide for example graph
three color ability as far as we know
and and this is kind of interesting when
the prover has some extra power or
knowledge for example maybe it has a
witness for three colorability of this
graph
or maybe it has extra computation power
it can solve problems
and and what we want to protect is that
the verifier
doesn't learn
anything beyond what it could have known
from the beginning so in particular for
example
the prover cannot just say hey look
here's the witness which is of course
would would convince the verifier but
this is information beyond just the fact
that x is in the language
and again kind of magically you can do
these things um
just maybe a
couple comments about graph three
colorability
so as a suppose that suppose that we
have this graph
uh one way that you can run such a
protocol and i'm not going to get into
specifics of how do you implement this
so suppose that i i'm the prover
i'm trying to to convince you as the
verifier
what i can do is i can randomize the
colors choose kind of a random
reassignment of the colors of my three
coloring
again i cover up all of the nodes so i
color the graph i cover up the nodes you
come into the room
and your challenge
you say to me give me
this on on one particular edge say a
random edge
uncover the two nodes of this edge
we open them up
you check are these one of the three
colors you're supposed to use and is it
the case that they're different
okay if not then i'm caught i'm busting
but if so
then with some probability
you
this okay so you would have to kind of
amplify you do this many many times
but kind of the important thing is that
if this graph is not three colorable
then however i choose the coloring there
is some edge that is miscolored and you
have some probability of finding that
edge so if you amplify enough times
you'd eventually get convinced that this
has to be three-colored
yeah but why is it zero knowledge
well what have you learned by this
instance
okay and when i say amplifying i mean
each time i have to choose a random kind
of
remapping of what the three colors are
so if this was white before now i'll
choose it blue or whatever
okay
so this is your knowledge because the
only thing your
your that's being revealed to you in
this execution
is an edge and two colors which are
different
that's something that you can simulate
on your own you can go to the side and
you can do that on your own
okay so so this is an example of the
type of framework of the zero knowledge
proof
okay so this this is this beautiful
classic uh notion from the 80s
and now starting with a bit of a twist
so what
what we
put forth
is a modified version of this
where you have zero knowledge
interactive proof again
on a distributed data
and what we mean by that
whereas before there was one verifier
that i was trying to convince
who had
who knew what what the graph was we knew
what x the statement was
and now we're considering a case where
maybe there's multiple verifiers maybe a
few of you are running this
but it might be the case that no single
verifier even knows x completely okay so
you
you guys know this part of the graph you
know this part of the graph or maybe you
have some sort of secret sharing of
information about the graph okay kind of
what we need is that there exists some
known
a linear combination of these pieces
that combine to give you x
so for example pieces uh directly give
you that
excellent
one another or something
and they don't want to reveal the code
to the judge so neither one wants to
reveal they both have pieces of this
secret yes
[Music]
and um
actually so i should mention that indeed
if you kind of throw generic secure
computation onto this
that's this is like a special case of
secure computation
okay but but because this is a special
instance
you can hope for much better protocols
and in fact we're sort of going to use
this as a tool to build better secure
computation
uh uh okay good good so a little bit
more about the setting here
um so so the verifiers as part of this
can communicate back and forth and in
particular
can
um
we don't really need that you share
randomness you can kind of sample
randomness and communicate
but but there is going to be
communication but we want that
communication to be relatively small
yes good so okay so let me kind of go
through what are the three
comparable uh properties that we want
here
so i think i'm not understanding the
setting but it seems to me that if
you're splitting up the knowledge of x
in some way there are cases where
verifying would become impossible like
what if there's two verifiers and it's a
bipartite graph and like
you know they're each verifier has a set
of vertices with no edges between them
like
yeah
how do we get around situations where
verifying seems impossible
okay good good
so
if the verifiers are honest we will
still be able to do things like that
which is a little bit tricky
um and it will be kind of how you what
what is it that you're communicating
back and forth but you're right that in
certain cases if verifiers subsets of
verifiers can be corrupt things get a
little sticky and that'll be down at the
bottom of this slide
okay so so first of all kind of though
the similar things to begin with
so we do want that that if the prover
is honest and x truly is in the language
we want it to be accepted
and and not by the way that the proverb
does know the statement completely knows
the input
okay the zero knowledge property
is going to be an analog of before but i
want to emphasize something in
particular okay so suppose suppose the
provers is honest
but a subset of the verifiers is corrupt
okay this is the analog of zero
knowledge from the previous slide where
the verify the verifier there was only
one was potentially corrupt
what we want is the exact analog that by
communicating in this whole protocol
this subset of verifiers
knows of course that x is in the
language
and it knows what it knew before
which is these pieces of of x
but it doesn't learn anything else and
in particular that means we don't even
want to reveal
other pieces of of x
before that's not something we had to
consider because both sides knew x
completely but now there's additional
information that we want to hide
okay and so now for soundness
um and this indeed gets a little bit
more
more fine-grained
so if let's suppose first of all suppose
that the prover
um is corrupt but all the verifiers are
on it
then it's a bit straightforward
we want it to be that if the verifiers
accept that means x is in the language
okay what becomes a little bit more
complicated is if some of the verifiers
can collude with with approver if
they're all corrupt
and the reason for that is to you know
what does that even mean what is it that
we're really proving
we're proven that this combined thing is
in the language
but not that the verifiers have some
power over kind of changing what this
combined thing is
okay so i'm not actually going to go
into detail about it
but it does make sense if it's the case
that these pieces of x have some sort of
robustness property
so for example if it's the case that if
i just took the set of honest verifiers
that already uniquely determine what is
what is x
so then it kind of makes sense what does
it mean that i'm proving this x he's in
the language or not
so take it back my example is
the verifier
suppose the approver is like an
individual
and part of this is my banking
information and part is my medical
information so i know both of these
things the bank knows one though the
hospital knows another
and i want to prove to an insurance
company that i you know have enough
money and that my medical situation is
good
can you confuse me whoever knows
everything yes
in this example
they don't trust majorly but they're
going to use
other verifiers yes
yes so for example say the bank trusts
the hospital and vice versa
yeah when you say plus you they're not
all colluding together right because in
that case then he could just give x to
the eyes so it's like crappy and corrupt
the eyes because
just a second so um
so in terms of revealing x if if the
prover is corrupt we're not really
trying to hide x from from anybody right
um then in any case that would be more
apt with zero knowledge so this is still
i'm still talking about the soundness
and here yes i do mean that they could
be colluding with each other
there could be an extra
yes yes this is also true so kind of as
before also if the food has an extra
witness
and as before you still don't want to
reveal the witness this is something
kind of on top of that
assistant do we consider a parallel
setting where the troopers interaction
with each verifier takes place at the
same time or it could be a compartment
where they have to take place at
different
um so the protocols that we
design or kind of consider are in some
sort of synchronous setting
but for example you can actually do
you can even do a very simple
communication structure where the prover
sends out one thing
um the verifiers need to kind of
choose a random string together
and send each other some answer based on
that random string and then decide
um so you can get better efficiency if
you have multiple rounds of
communication in which case we do
consider a synchronous setting okay but
even though this is conversion to do
something
so
i'm identifying that uh i was a little
overly excited with the amount of
content i wanted to squeeze into this
talk so we skipped some future stuff but
but this is good i you know i want to at
least give you some some high-level
ideas of things
okay so um so one of the high-level
comments here
is that in this setting in this
distributed data setting
there's some interesting new questions
that sort of open up so for example
before with the standard zero knowledge
if the language l is simple
it's a little bit pointless
okay so so for example
suppose that verify one knows all of x
and the language is something very
simple that for example if i look at the
different symbols of x there's some
quadratic uh constraint that's satisfied
by them
okay i can give you a very simple zero
knowledge proof i don't send you
anything
okay and you go to the side and you
check with x does this actually satisfy
okay so in the standard case this is
only sort of interesting for hard
languages l
in our case that's not the case
in our setting that's not the case
okay so and and here this is because
nobody can check this directly on their
own for example maybe that my relation
is that if i take this symbol that
you're holding times this symbol that
you're holding is equal to the symbol
that you're holding this is already
something that's very interesting
okay and um
so i'll say a little bit about new
applications of this setting
uh of of this tool which has you know
different kinds of complexity goals
compared to
things that the people who
or like were mostly considered in the
other case
so in particular i'm going to be really
interested in how much communication is
going on here what is the sort of the
proof size that the prover has to send
verifiers
okay so i'm going to give a little bit
of an abbreviated version of this
but i want to give you a high-level
flavor of um sort of where do we build
these things how do we get them i will
not go into depth
and i also want to show you how can you
use this in order to get this arrow up
this compiler from passive to active
security
in secure computation protocols
and the punch lines especially if i
don't get to some parts um so for the
first part
i want to to kind of emphasize so we can
get very low cost protocols for simple
languages we're simple for example
degree 2 constant degree um
so forth and the low cost is going to be
very small communication sublinear even
in the input size of the size x
okay and in
using this the punch line of the second
part is exactly we get this arrow that
goes up
from a certain protocols with passive
security up to to active this is a
malicious sometimes used instead of
active security
where the the additive overhead is
linear in the circuit side
okay
so uh
so the construction part as i said i'm
going to keep high level
um but as a function of this maybe i'll
also teach you guys a little bit about
uh something called pcps
okay so
probably a lot of you have seen this but
at a high level so a pcp or
probabilistically checkable proof
right
this is a setting where a
approver takes the the x
and and witness if they have one
and spits out some proof potentially
wrong proof pi
verification procedure
chooses a small number of positions of
the proof to check
in order to verify
that x is in the language again if i put
things in blue are things that the
verifier sees so the verifier knows the
statement and kind of looks into a small
number of positions of this proof
and this is this fun thing where they
said you know what if you in order to
review a paper you demanded that the the
authors instead of writing this proof
actually wrote a pcp
okay and then as the reviewer you only
have to look at three parts of the proof
and decide whether it's correct or not
wouldn't that be fantastic
okay and this is a so something back in
the 90s it was shown that for
for any mp language that you can
actually achieve such a thing
so i'm i'm not going to talk about how
do you achieve any of these things
but i want to give you just a little bit
of the flavor of variations of pcps that
exist in the literature
okay so perhaps fewer fewer of you have
heard of something called a linear pcp
it is a very similar sort of setting
where the verifier sees a statement the
approver generates this proof and the
verifier doesn't get to see the proof
and home
okay over here
the the verifier got to look at specific
symbols of the proof
and here it's actually more power to the
verifier
where where what the verifier gets to do
is say give me this linear combination
of the proof symbols
so they give us like a this is specified
by some coefficient vector and you get
the inner product
of the coefficient vector with whatever
this proof is okay so it's still
shrinking i'm only getting a little bit
of information
um but it's a little bit more powerful
because for example i can capture pcp
queries by just specific instances where
i just have like a one in hidden
position okay that would pull out one
symbol of this thing
again because of the stronger power of
the prover you can get some better
properties sorry the stronger power of
the verifier
some of you maybe didn't know all these
feel the flavors existed
um but but i want to emphasize so
remember that we're in a setting where
the verifier does not know the statement
so i want to kind of step over into that
regime
and there does exist a notion called pcp
of proximity
which is similar to pcp
except you'll note here that the
statement is no longer blue
so in this setting and protocols for
this exist
the verifier only gets to make access
into symbols of the proof and also
symbols of the statement
so on the plus side this is saying the
verifier even has less
downside of this or one of the downsides
is that you can't actually ever
guarantee through this process that x
that's written here is in the language
why because for example maybe it's
almost in the language but one symbol is
flipped it's a low probability you're
ever going to hit that symbol
so the only thing that you can actually
assert in such a such a proof system
is that whatever x is written here is
close to the language
it doesn't have too many symbols away
from something that needs
this box is what i've been waiting for
this fully linear pcp
okay so kind of take the squeeze of
these two things
this is a notion that we put forth in a
in a paper back in in 2019
it's it's the x is close in language or
is it there is
close to five
which is correct
um it doesn't
it doesn't matter so much uh like we
don't really care if there exists a
close proof
um the final st the final conclusion at
the end is just that whatever is here is
something that is close to the language
but it's kind of just a tool along the
way
okay so this is a fully linear pcp as
maybe you can extrapolate from the
pictures here
it's a setting where the verifier does
not know the statement
and the queries that the verifier makes
are linear queries
okay but instead of just being over the
proof
now they can be completely near
combinations across the proof and the
statement
and and so what are kind of the pros and
cons
well so these are stronger
types of queries than this of course
and because of that
because for example my query can kind of
smear together some linear combination
of all the symbols of x
you can actually
assert
in some of these these protocols
that if the verifier accepts then x
itself is in the language not just that
it's close but it is in the language
so that is fully linear like linear in x
and also linear and fine
and that's just the best name but before
it was just
yes yes
okay so in other words you don't know
that you don't read all of it when you
do
um you need to sort of the
the
so in the kind of though the model here
the answer the query answers are
generated as a function of all mags
but the verifier does not get access to
x it only gets linear query access so
again it's a lot like here this is
compressing in the sense that you know
here you get like five symbols here you
also get five symbols but they're
computed as a function of all of the
symbols yeah
they're not like that
you know
implicitly is then if x is already
written in
error correcting form then some of the
symbols that are written down are
already linear combinations of all
ex-citizens
yeah yeah
okay
and good and so so in fact for actually
each of these things you can also
consider a zero knowledge version of the
the thing where the extra zero knowledge
is that
um as a function of for example the
verifier queries you don't learn
anything
beyond that x is in the language so in
particular here for example you can
design the protocol so that
the queries are not actually leaking
information about x directly
okay so let me
maybe i'll take the quick vote you wanna
i can either talk about how if you have
such a thing that gives you zero
knowledge on distributed data or talk
about how you can use your knowledge on
distributed data to give you the arrow
which one
the first one okay i think i think it
will do that otherwise it's a lot from
the other side good so suppose that i i
have such a thing
okay and actually let me let me
maybe briefly
okay so so let me pause and say are
there any questions about what this
object is so slightly more formally
there's some sort of prover algorithm
the program has the statement and the
witness and generates this proof
and the verifier needs to make queries
that are describable as linear
combinations with some coefficient
vector here
and gets us answers the inner product
between the coefficient vectors
and the concatenation of these two
things
how is this hiding x at all why can't
you just like
um
do indicator functions to get x out i
don't see that yet
it can be made your knowledge i'm not
really saying much about that okay but
you can make it that sort of think about
it like honest verifies your knowledge
that if you do the queries you're
supposed to then you
in this case so i haven't written here
we will be interested in hiding x
um and kind of just why is it okay to
think about honest verifiers and
knowledge in our setting the answer is
going to be because so we have these
multiple verifiers and sort of they'll
jointly
generate the queries so this will
enforce that the queries will actually
be honest
questions about
okay awesome so suppose that we have
this
and again this is kind of like an
abstract thing on its own with some you
know magical query answering
uh that it's not clear like who's doing
this query answering but it somehow
comes
to the verifier
and now let me describe to you an
example of how you can use nut to give
this zero knowledge on distributed data
okay so so the prover starts with x
maybe some witness
and first runs this this proof protocol
to generate the proof pi
note that the prover it's not
necessarily okay to just send the proof
okay and why is that so kind of going
back to here remember that this zero
knowledge property is only guaranteed
given these
these the query
query answers in particular the zero
knowledge property doesn't like it
doesn't expect that the verifier can see
the proof
but don't worry that's not going to be
prom
you can just the approver will take the
proof and additively secret share across
the two parties so what does this mean
this means this is actually just a
totally random string and each symbol
here is such that this symbol because
this symbol is the real symbol of pi
okay so now we have kind of this piece
over here
now the verifier
will jointly decide the query the
verifier queries
from the fully linear pcp
okay
how do you have a little there's
different ways of exist like queen
tossing protocols where the two of us
can just generate a random string
together that will be honestly random
okay
that defines
this this sort of compressing linear
function here
now
each verifier
neither verifier actually has pi
together with x
but we have something let's suppose that
if i take
this this part suppose that for example
this verifier only has these symbols of
x
and this additive secret share of y
okay well say that it just computes this
linear combination of whatever it's got
here
this verifier does the same
now what is what are these two answers
how can i combine these to get the
actual answer of the verifier query
in this case i could just add them
together
why is that so think about this is
describing some linear combination of
for example now i've got zeros here and
actual symbols
uh in some secret sharing and the
linearity of these queries the fact that
this is a linear function
means that you can kind of do this in
different order either
first add these together then take the
linear function or take the linear
functions and then add it together
and uh and i claimed that this so now
now the verifiers each of them they
exchange these values i indeed add them
together
as in a function of that
they can decide whether to accept or
reject
and i've described it as sort of a
one-shot process it's not really a
problem if you have interaction you need
to do multiple rounds or things the
exact same structure works
okay so so this gives we want
completeness
by the correctness of this thing this
this will give us exactly the complete
like follows from the completeness of
the previous line
soundness
actually let me get to sound this in a
second why is this zero knowledge
okay this is coming from the fact that
this tool is going to be zero knowledge
and the only thing that you're really
revealing here you're exchanging just
the query answers
okay so the only thing that though the
verifiers are learning
are exactly
the answers to these queries
and um
and why is it sound okay well so let me
kind of do the simple version suppose
that the verifiers are both honest okay
then soundness here is going to exactly
follow from the soundness of the the
fully linear pc pieces
okay good so um
so let me just kind of mention
what do we know how what do we actually
know about building this will be linear
pcp
well it turns out that the many
uh pcp or regular linear pcp
constructions from the literature
actually already have this natural
structure
um for our particular setting where
we're interested in really pushing down
the the proof size like what is this the
length of pi
okay i kind of purposely wrote pi
is something short here because this is
what we want and we can achieve for
simple languages so here for example the
pi is even sublinear
in the size of of the combined x
again and for this setting so indeed by
looking at these simple languages um
here so these are like x's which are
vectors of field elements
um that are where the
the language itself is expressible say
by degree two or some constant degree
expression then we can get roughly say
like square root of the size of of the x
for a one shot thing
um what is an iop well i didn't really
tell you this this is called an
interactive oracle proof this is like a
kind of an interactive version of a pcp
where you have to do rounds of
communication back and forth and here we
can get the total combined proof size to
logarithmic
uh you'll note they didn't write any
computational assumptions here there's a
very good reason for that because we
don't need any this is a purely
information information theoretic object
um and uh
and here so so the error
the soundness error in these cases is
like one over field signs
so if your field happens to be very
large this is already fantastic
but if you have something small say i'm
looking at boolean my
my statements and my things are just
bits
this is pretty crafty
but don't worry um because you can you
can do a natural amplification
um by i won't really explain how but
um you can do like basically embedding
your elements into a larger ring or
field extension
you can ask me about that afterwards
you're interested in
okay so i uh
picture yeah
oh sorry
this is the secret sheriff of the proof
and the verifiers somehow
like
and they can talk to each other yes yes
so but they might need the cooper again
or do
it depends on what your original
the original linear function your pcp
setting is in that case um if it's just
like you can make one shot queries then
you just need to do it one shot
um if the original thing requires more
communication then you sort of inherit
executive structures
in particular these these um
the i will is the interactive oracle
proofs this is the thing where each
round the cooper like sends an
additional piece
okay
so due to time let me vary just briefly
i'll keep it quite brief but i do want
to just give you a very very high level
view of how do you stick this this tool
in to give you such a compiler
okay so so here's the very high level
plan
remember that the goal now is to go from
a secure multi-party computation
protocol against just passive
adversaries and boost up to kind of
enforce a security even against active
malicious adversaries
and this is going to be the plan
so start with your original passive
secure protocol
um our transformation will work for for
ones that have a particular natural
structure
the definition as always the definition
of natural became a little bit gross
uh i don't know how natural it is but
the good news is that it's at least
satisfied by essentially any protocol
that's out there of course you can
design a horrible protocol that does not
satisfy this okay but the natural ones
too
okay so take take your your seminars
protocol
and such a natural protocol has the
structure that up until the very last
message
actually you're not learning anything
you're just basically sending out secret
shares of things it's basically garbage
then at the very last round you will
send the final message which sort of
reveals what all this garbage truly
meant i have like
two very detailed signs of an example of
a proof that i skipped over here but i
can show them to you after if you're
interested okay so trust trust me on
this
um so our plan is going to be to run
the semi honest protocol up until this
very last round
didn't stick in an extra stage here
and by the way this framework is not new
to us
um but but how how this will be
implemented will be different
again the goal will be to somehow
stop freeze frame everything right here
and before you send this message which
could reveal information
um and and by the way so the guarantee
is that if people really acted
semi-honestly here
then whatever is going to be sent is
safe
but if people were cheating here sending
this last message might reveal my input
okay so i don't want to send this unless
i'm convinced
that all of you were actually acting
semi-honestly up in the first part
and this is what we're going to stick in
here
okay
so if if in this space
somebody's not convinced then they'll
just abort okay so we're not getting
like a guaranteed output delivery but
some kind of security with the board and
you can actually build on top of this in
certain cases so to also
ensure conclusion
okay so just kind of very very briefly
let me describe one way that you can
kind of execute this this blue box and
it turns out there's different sorts of
blueprint frameworks of how to stick
this in
um so i'd be happy to talk about that
okay so
so what's going to happen
our execution of this type 1
is that at the
at this page right here
each and every party who's running on
the protocol
is going to separately act as prover to
everybody else
and the other parties in the protocol
are acting like the multiple verifiers
what am i proving what is even the
statement of the language here
my my input my x
is going to be just a concatenation
squashing together
each and every message that i ever sent
out or received to anybody
okay note that i know this completely
because i sent or received it
and you should know how exactly some
piece of that which is my communication
to and from you
now what is the thing i want to prove
i need to assert to you collectively
that the combination of all of these
messages
were computed as they were supposed to
as dictated by the protocol
and as it turns out
you know on these detailed slides
for for these natural protocols
essentially everything that's out there
the computations i'm supposed to do in
each and every step
is a degree to function
okay so i receive messages from
from you collectively
various pairs of these things i kind of
multiply maybe i add something and i
send that out to somebody else
okay so this is exactly
the setting where we have good solutions
where we have
these uh zero knowledge proofs on
distributed data
where the proof size this extra
communication the the secret shares of
pi that had to get sent were small they
were sublime
in the the x that we began with
okay
so what do we end up doing
um again so you run the first part of
the protocol before you send the last
message each and every one of us proves
to everybody else that these messages
from the first part were concluded
correctly
and if it truly is the case if everybody
is accepting
that means that this first this great
part here
was done correctly
and that gives you that it's safe to
reveal your final message
okay and and what is the overhead in the
communication well it's really just this
extra communication of this protocol
for
for each each party acting as approver
by the way you can also do them all in
parallel you don't have to do one type
one
and collectively this extra
communication really amounts just to
the proof size which we said is
sublinear in the original communication
of the first part of the protocol
plus whatever the verifiers are
communicating which also turns out to be
quite small
and that kind of bottom line here so
this extra communication is sublinear
in the circuit signs
so
this is this is what i promised you at
the beginning of the talk
um
i'm
i'm not going to say
anything about this let me just sort of
tease you with
everything that i've described
uh
works in the setting where you have an
honest majority and this comes into play
because i i do need some sort of
robustness of the messages that are
doing here remember we said that there
was something that
turns out this does hold for honest
majority protocols
but the question if it's the case that
everybody except for one party is
malicious
um then things become more tricky but
also more interesting and it turns out
that you can still apply these
techniques so you can ask me about that
okay but so to conclude
uh what did we have on our journey
together today
so kind of the takeaways that i want you
to remember first of all this notion the
zero knowledge undistributed data
um i think it's quite interesting and i
think it has a lot of potential
applications
a little bit about construction so this
notion of fully linear processing or an
interactive version we didn't really see
much about
and the fact that for simple languages
that you can do this with very small
subliminal food
and some of the positives here
so this is the the the step that we're
sticking in this blue box we're sticking
with the protocol does not add any
computational assumptions so whatever
the original protocol needed that's
exactly what the final protocol means
and also something very cool
it works automatically
for any fields and in fact
rings of form z mod n
that holds for free you can do this in
the setting for boolean circuits you can
do it for big fields you can do for
small fields you can do it for
computations over the links in the end
and you don't need to come up with
specific targeted protocols for each of
these cases which is what you used to
have to do
um in kind of works beforehand so in
particular for example the boolean case
there's a lot more complication because
you get small like bad soundness and so
and as i mentioned and this gives you
these these applications just a linear
communication overhead of going from
passive to active security
i think i'm
sort of overstayed my welcome here for
this talk um but just to mention a
couple open questions there's a lot of
really interesting directions trying to
build better underlying tools
um trying to look at different passive
to active compilers
uh for example we still need certain
type of structure in the original
protocol in order for this to go through
and there's a lot of other types of
protocol structures that exist out there
um be really interesting to try to see
if you can extend these for example even
just even just if instead of addition
and multiplication gates you had
more rich
sorts of bases of gates in your circuit
okay and with that i will conclude
so this that question i think already
applies even in from here to here
exactly yes yes so there are um
oh actually i don't have a good like
quick answer to give you but there are
definitely settings where this does give
you more power
um
so i understand some of you have to
check out
just